how's it going residence today we're
gonna play Barbie bite really first of
all Jesus Christ there's so many barbie
games thank you
I can pick up any [ __ ] Barbie title
right there and there's a game for there
let's put it to test all right
Barbie rectal examination well I take it
back they don't have everything so this
is on a Brazilian website Jacques or
dice pay a bottle by the bottle be not
about the bottle be great what are the
sisters doing scissoring each other
stop it scissors you'll get it when
you're older
Barbie suffered a terrible accident
while she was visiting a radioactive
laboratory what would she do in visiting
a Larry add something went wrong and now
barbie is suffering beard started to
grow in her face helped her recover from
this accident and make her look
beautiful again
now polo polo polo are you saying may it
sound beautiful
[ __ ] you Barbie you look fabulous I
don't understand the problem I guess
we'll have to apply the cream and we had
dry it we hairdryer beard i doubt some
new up Barbie hey Bobby what are you
doing
this is not how men shave oh right I
don't know about women but I looks great
Barbie you look fabulous
let's calm it down a little bit great
you look do you now look like Satan or
Mel Gibson for that matter I don't
[ __ ] god damn it this is not working
the [ __ ] am I supposed to do oh my god
what are all these [ __ ] things oh my
god I can make it grow more what the
[ __ ] I thought the point was to I can
diet all right let's make it black you
look so good Barbie she looks like egg
man Jesus Christ gross under Chin's like
what the [ __ ] now listen up Barbie I
know what you're doing and I'm not okay
with it stop stop this nonsense what is
this I can drag on tattoos now why would
you get a face tattoo of a [ __ ] sword
I can save it it's now on my computer
forever thank you
it's pretty [ __ ] good game I don't
know what to tell you wait Barbie
murderer what the [ __ ]
Barbie what did you do Barbie what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you how it how is
this okay what the [ __ ] is this that was
a that was [ __ ] a you just had done
oh my god best best best best Barbie at
dr. game why is she wearing that no one
wears that at a doctor Barbie I hate to
tell you why is she crying like a
[ __ ] baby seriously you're not two
years old
I [ __ ] played this game already this
is a frozen game they just changed
Barbie shut up you fake Hitler Barbie
all right
thought we talked about this Barbie
what's with the different noises oh my
god oh yeah have a [ __ ] tattoo it while
you're at it you're welcome
I can move the tattoo Val looks great
[Applause]
[Music]
83% liked this game 83% are [ __ ] out
of their goddamn mind good job doc why
thank you now please put some goddamn
clothes on you [ __ ]
all right Barbie sport or plastic
surgery hey hey is that Elsa she really
just comes in with a [ __ ] hamburger
in her hand always ready you never know
when you need one let's meet in half a
year to share our results
good idea see you please be her plastic
surgeon while you're asking a lot here
I'm not technically a certified click
anywhere Oh Oh God what is all this oh
[ __ ] here comes ah I don't even do it
properly what the [ __ ] let's just suck
that out with a vacuum oh yeah
Oh
no no why no more please Oh
job well done Barbie friend printed
thank you Barbie what the [ __ ] did you
do did you snort cocaine again this is
not acceptable
god I hate the face screams oh it's so
nasty you do look like a demon from hell
you know that right I'm squeezing Barbie
pimples this is the highest point of my
life oh god I don't know nope I played
some scary games in my days but that
that about does it right there the game
has 40% loaded clear subside the game
now
they [ __ ] lied hey [ __ ] lie Hema
Barbie Emo's there's a shop called emos
I don't know if anyone told you Barbie
but you're not wearing any clothes great
Barbie you're now a prostitute that's it
ten out of ten idea I love how you can
finish some of these games in literally
like two seconds
people should speed run these barbie
games okay Barbie what happened
we gonna make you look fabulous barbecue
shut up you like it oh yeah girl you're
looking fine you're looking fine girl
she looks like a final fantasy character
this is so cool looks so good oh my god
Barbie
shut up what you look so good come on
come on Barbie don't give me that leg I
love when they live the game like - save
it for it for your computer like what am
I supposed to do with this [ __ ]
picture
I have some glasses oh my god that looks
great what what
Barbie burgers hi Barbie today I'm going
to cook burger just burger you're going
to cook Park it for my boyfriend boy I
rent I don't have a boyfriend all right
let's cut the beef I don't know they
just put a chef's hat on it oh my god I
hate you flatten that beef out make it
like a nice little beef curtain oh god
it's so big
ah I'm clicking like a [ __ ] how
they're not nothing in happening are
these dead baby tongues this is almost
like we're kicking I love it oh my god
this game never ends
Oh God
Ken ah ah ah what are you doing try to
[ __ ] cook here you son of a ass stop
stop place the pan of this strap or oil
and die yeah this is the most annoying
game ever oh my god get off me face I
think Ken has some relationship issues
where's the [ __ ] garlic gonna finish
this [ __ ] game if it's the last thing
I ever do this is almost as fun as
picking Barbies it's off her face finn's
what the [ __ ] they're not muffins
alright now I'm going to taste the
dishes and tell my judgment
really that [ __ ] face I can tell
you're not being sincere Barbie
[Music]
what why we're invisible now no one can
see you I still think Barbie murderer is
my favorite I got it
teaching kids how to murder they never
they look like they have something stuck
up their eyes well if it's downloading
then you need to [ __ ] stop oh my god
she's so scary what the [ __ ] look at the
arms they come with it
Barbie knows Barbie knows dr. feel like
I've played this Oh God
how does life even come to this this
there's stuff living inside your nose
Barbie I'm sorry no I'm no no no no no
no no I'm you know watching
it's a sky camera today I will see you
in the next Barbie game no wait Oh
[Music]